in 40 province some 50 kilometers east
of Saigon a Chinook helicopter arrives
at an artillery position of the Royal
New Zealand army the men and guns are to
be flown to a new location in the
province the internal loading of the
aircraft is expedited as the New Zealand
unit prepares to support Australian
troops engaged in operation Ingham the
date is 28 November sling loaded
material is hooked up and the utility
helicopter lifts off and heads south
eastward toward the zone of operations a
few metres from this landing zone the
first Australian Task Force is seeking
enemy supplies and supply routes to
Royal armoured regiments are conducting
the sweep
now the artillery unit is arriving the
New Zealand artillery men begin digging
in as soon as their equipment is
offloaded they start setting up camp
meanwhile troops of the Australian
contingent who had earlier secure the
battery position carry out a perimeter
guard patrol it is suspected that the VC
may try to hit the artillery position
with mortars patrolling units keep in
touch by radio as they comb the area on
the 29th of November the day after the
New Zealanders landed the battery fires
a mission in support of Australian AP
sees the Australian armored has made
contact with some VC and the artillery
is hitting enemy positions
3000 meters from the artillery position
the Australian armored vehicles begin
moving in on the enemy now at close
range the men from Down Under are hit by
a hail of small arms fire they return
the fire using both thirty and fifty
caliber automatic weapons
abruptly the enemy ceases firing and the
Royal Australian armored vehicles push
on continuing the search but the enemy
has fled and is nowhere to be found
at a pre-arranged rendezvous point a
Chinook helicopter brings in a load of
collapsible fuel tanks from which the
APCs will refuel in the field on the
morning of the 30th of November the
Australians commence refuelling
operations the crews quickly hooking up
the necessary hoses and pumps then one
by one the armored vehicles are service
when the refueling is completed the
Australian starts circling back to their
base searching for VC as they go the
area is covered with elephant grass they
soon discover a large enemy bunker with
an associated network of tunnels the
entire complex is thoroughly searched
and though abandoned by the Vietcong it
contains nearly 30 tons of polished rice
the searchers explore the various
entrances with extreme caution
the rice is destroyed and the taskforce
moves out through the jungles and scrub
growth of the coastal province one of
the hazards encountered on the return
trip to camp is a swiftly flowing river
control cables are used to guide the
armored personnel carriers across these
treacherous waters finally the vehicles
of the Royal Australian armored regiment
reached civilization once again and pass
through a barbed wire fence and arrived
in camp enemy prisoners taken during the
two days search and clear mission are
brought to the camp's airstrip here they
are transferred to an RAF helicopter for
transport to the regimental headquarters
where they will be interrogated
on 3 December operation Ingham comes to
a successful conclusion
in fact we province 64 kilometers
northeast of Saigon in the province of
Port we our village is about to be
destroyed by elements of the 11th
Armored Cavalry but first the people
must be evacuated along with their
belongings for some time now the village
has been infested with the VC the
surrounding area is leveled as
operations begin at the request of the
Vietnamese provincial chief the work of
demolishing the village begins
flamethrowers are used for the job
in the distance an airstrike hits a
group of DC fleeing from the area
following the fiery destruction of the
village armored vehicles move in and mow
down a thick banana Grove there is to be
nothing left which might be of use to
the enemy even these fruit trees must be
denied the VC Vietcong snipers wounded
one cavalrymen while trying to deter the
Americans from destroying the village a
flying ambulance is called in the
injured man is soon aboard the Dustoff
chopper and airborne for the hospital on
the highway for below the Vietnamese
villagers are rolling toward a life of
freedom from oppression at the
relocation center the operation is over
in a valiant bendin province 25
kilometers southwest of bong-sun
elements of the first Air Cavalry
conduct a sweep through Vietcong control
territory it is 20 December and the
action is part of Operation Thayer -
after light contact with the enemy the
unit advances to find one dead VC and
nearby a badly wounded Vietcong officer
he has passed into shock and a medic
quickly provides emergency aid to save
his life
as soon as possible a chopper is called
in to evacuate the wounded prisoner he
will be taken to a nearby field hospital
and if he recovers will be subject to a
thorough interrogation operation faier -
which began on 25 October and has thus
far accounted for more than 600 enemy
dead continues successfully
at long Binh on 11 December an awards
ceremony is held for the 145th combat
aviation battalion and attached units
General William C Westmoreland arrives
with Colonel Raymond P Campbell
commander of the 12th combat aviation
group as participating troops present
arms the distinguished Unit Citation for
extraordinary heroism says in part when
the besieged defenders of Dong so I
requested assistance the 145th aviation
battalion responded
although the insurgents had all
approaches covered by 50 caliber machine
guns and heavy automatic weapons
general Westmoreland fastens the
streamer to the battalion colors as
Colonel Campbell assists the general
addresses the heliborne troops referring
to the citation which concludes the
determination indomitable courage and
extraordinary heroism demonstrated by
these units participating with the 145th
aviation battalion are in the highest
traditions of the military service
on 21 December an Air Force jet puts
down a tonne salute Air Force Base
among those debarking are the Army's
chief of staff general Harold K Johnson
and sergeant major of the army
William o Wooldridge arriving in Vietnam
for a Christmas visit on hand to greet
the visitors as general Westmoreland
commander in chief McVie the army's top
enlisted man is returning to vietnam for
meetings and visits with the troops
while the generals confer sergeant
Wooldridge visits with enlisted men of
the 18th replacement company hope if
you're I should come by Washington we
stop and see me succeed all from
California good luck to you I may see
you out at Fort Sill
all the best to you Jarvis nice to see
you the sergeant major then visits the
wards and nurses at the 93rd evacuation
Hospital I'm going to leave from Saigon
on the 28th and going directly into
Dallas Texas resolutely and our get
control air I understand we're going to
talk to some nursing there Dallas
arrival and I've been asked to bring
something from you because at the time
and understand you're gonna give me one
of your very nice [ __ ] package here
from 9:30 back which the hospital so be
proud and very happy to represent you
air and potential patch to the nurses
are Dallas I want to tell you and I know
that I speak for all the soldiers when I
tell you this how grateful we are for
your help my visit the hospitals around
the states and my travels there and I
talk to a lot of soldiers who have been
processed through your hospital here on
back to the states and they always tell
me how wonderful the nurses are and so I
know I speak for all them when I say to
you will we're grateful and very proud
that if you're a member of our team we
certainly thank you for you
two soldiers the sergeants trip would
not be complete without a visit to his
old unit but big red one I'd like to say
well I have the opportunity that I wish
all of our soldiers around the world a
very Merry Christmas Happy New Year and
I look forward to seeing you all in the
future I run an office for you bit and
and then the Pentagon I hope that you'll
contact me there if I can be assistants
to you and I hope that you're in the
Washington area you'll stop in and see
your office thank you
at headquarters field force 1 in Natron
on 21 December officers and news men are
on hand for the arrival of general new
Yin Phan chu chief of state of the
Republic of Vietnam general Chu is
greeted by general william Westmoreland
commander in chief McVie and general
Stanley Larsen commander of field force
one the occasion is the presentation of
awards to staff officers of field force
one general Chu is presenting the medals
to the officers on behalf of the
Republic of Vietnam in appreciation for
their gallant service in the current
conflict with generals Westmoreland and
Larsen congratulating the men the spirit
of warm cooperation between the United
States and the Republic of Vietnam is
reflected throughout the formal
presentation
at the Pentagon on 19 December 1966 a
distinguished assembly attends the
presentation of the Medal of Honor to
first lieutenant Walter J marm jr. in a
special army full honor award ceremony
the honors include a 19-gun salute the
Secretary of the army and the chief of
staff accompany Lieutenant mARMS
inspection of the honor guard Secretary
Stanley our research addresses the
formation and guests I am honored today
to represent President Johnson at this
ceremony we are gathered to present this
nation's highest award to first
lieutenant Walter J marm jr. personal
courage is a magnificent thing the
ability to lead other men in the face of
extreme danger is a rare gift
today we honor a young army officer who
early in his military career combine
these two qualities to meet the test of
combat against a trained and determined
full lieutenant marm takes us place
before the color guard for the citation
major-general Kenneth G Wickham the
adjutant general reads the citation his
company was moving through the valley to
relieve a friendly unit surrounded by an
enemy force of estimated regimental
sighs lieutenant marm led his platoon
through withering fire until they were
finally forced to take cover realizing
that his platoon could not hold very
long and seeing four enemy moving into
his position he moved quickly under
heavy fire and annihilated all four then
seeing that his platoon was receiving
intense fire from
concealed machine-gun he deliberately
exposed himself to draw its fire thus
locating its position he attempted to
destroy it with an anti-tank weapon
although he inflicted casualties the
weapon did not silence the enemy fire
quickly disregarding the intense fire
directed on him in his platoon he
charged 30 meters across open ground and
hurled grenades into the enemy position
killing some of the eight insurgents
manning is although severely wounded
when his grenades were expended armed
with only a rifle he continued the
momentum of his assault on the position
and killed the remainder of the enemy
lieutenant mARMS selfless actions
reduced the fire on his platoon broke
the enemy assault and rallied his unit
to continue toward the accomplishment of
its mission the Medal of Honor is
presented to lieutenant marm by
secretary racer for conspicuous
gallantry on the battlefield and
extraordinary intrepidity above and
beyond the call of duty